الحقيقه ليست بعيده عن الواقع الراهن هي
هي وثقه الصله كيف يتلقى افراد الاخوان ما
يبث في اعلام الاخوان
الجماعه بتربي ابناءها واعضائها في تربيه
محضانيه مقاولبه ان اعلام الجماعه العام
ليس مصدرا للتلقي
ويربونهم في كتب يعتمدها قسم التربيه ان
اذا رايتم قياده الجماعه تشيد ببعض القوى
السياسيه او توجد مع مساحات مشتركه فليس
معنى هذا ان هذا امر
تتبنه الجماعه او انه الراي الرسمي
للجماعه هو مجرد محاوله للتقارب وايجاد
مساحات مع عدو قريب الى نسقط العدو الاقوى
هكذا يدرسون في كتاب المنهج الحركي للسيره
النبويه في كتابات سعيد حوا في كتابات
القديمه الفتح هي كان قبل ان يترك الجماعه
يدرسونها في بها محضنيه ان اعلام الجماعه
ليس مصدرا للتلقي وانما المصدر التلقي
الوحيد هو ما ياتي بالطريق بالتنظيمي